trying to see how many times does this
go into this so let's set it up like a
long division problem what I have here
is I've got X minus 1 is dividing into
4x squared minus 2x plus 3 okay so
you're with me so far so what we do here
is we say how many times does X go into
this first term 4x squared and there's a
lot of different ways to do this you can
find your favorite way you could say
well what's 4x squared divided by X well
that's gonna be four acts and you might
be wondering why did I put it here I'm
just lining the X's up okay another way
to do it and this is how I actually do
it I say to myself hmm what times X
gives me 4x squared okay because what I
want to do when I subtract I want this
first term to cancel out so what we're
gonna do now is we're going to
distribute the 4x okay so that's going
to be 4x squared minus 4x and then what
we're gonna do is we're going to
subtract okay but what a lot of students
like to do is subtraction is really like
adding the opposite so if I change these
signs to the opposite and just add
straight down that often times is a lot
easier you can see these are cancelling
we get 2x plus 3 so I'm just adding
straight down okay now what I'm trying
to do is say what times X is 2x or you
could say what's 2 X divided by X well 2
X divided by X is 2 and what I do is I
distribute that 2 to both these terms so
that's gonna be 2x minus 2 now I
subtract well I like to do is change the
science to the opposite and add those
cancel and we're left with 5 now you can
see that 5 is up a constant it's
actually called degree 0 this is degree
1 see if first degree first power this
degree is lower than this degree which
means that this is our remainder now
what do we do with the remainder we put
the remainder over the divisor which in
this case is what X minus 1 and that's
our final answer
okay it's just kind of like if you said
how many times does 6 go into 23 times
remainder 2 now what do you do with the
2 you say 3 & 2 6 and you can reduce
that down you put the remainder over the
divisor let's go to the second example
a second example same idea we have a
little bit more challenging though I
should say we've got 3 X minus 1 is
going into 6 x squared minus 3 X plus 9
okay so you're with me so far
so
how many times is 3x going to 6x squared
or you could say what's 6x squared
divided by 3x or you can do it my way
which is to basically just say what
times 3x is 6x squared and that's going
to be 2x so if I distribute the 2x I get
6x squared you always want to match that
first term so when you subtract they
cancel out 2x times negative 1 is
negative 2x and then you can subtract
but it's easier to change the signs to
the opposite can just add same thing
we're not doing anything different we're
just subtraction is adding the opposite
now all we say hmm how many times is 3x
going to negative x or you could say
what's negative x divided by 3x or you
could say like I was doing what times 3x
is negative x and I can see that that's
going to be negative 1/3 so if I
distribute that that gives me negative x
and this gives me positive 1/3 now what
we're going to do is want to change the
science to the opposite and add so those
are going to cancel out and 9 is really
like hmm 27 thirds minus 1/3 is 26
thirds
what do you do with the remainder see
how this degree is degree 0 this is
degree 1 this is lower than this so
that's a remainder we put the remainder
over the divisor so I'm just going to
put over here plus 26 thirds over 3x
minus 1 now this is a little